hello everybody and welcome to this
tutorial on a new career opportunity to
come and work for the EU institutions
episode has published a competition to
select economists and on its dedicated
page on the website you will find this
infographic showing you the different
steps to take to become a successful
candidate and in this tutorial we will
explain these different steps in detail
the competition has three Fields micro
and macroeconomics Financial economics
and Industrial economics and as a
candidate you can only apply for one
field so you have to make a choice here
you see the number of successful
candidates and as you can see they're
quite high in total we are looking to
select 970 economists which is indeed a
massive number
this is an ad6 grade competition meaning
you need either a master degree plus
three years of experience in the field
of your choice
or a bachelor degree plus four years of
experience in the field of your choice
one exception for the second field
Financial economics you can still apply
with another degree than the one in the
field but then you need to be able to
prove more years of professional
experience
anyhow please read the notice of
competitions
carefully because there we explain these
eligibility criteria in detail
you will set your tests in two different
languages and one of the two languages
must be English for this competition
recently we have adopted a new
competition model meaning that our
selection procedure has changed a bit it
has become shorter in duration
and it has become less complex
there are three stages starts with an
application of course then there is a
testing phase and after that we
communicate your results the big novelty
lies in the testing phase
you will sit the three tests mentioned
here on this slide in one single day
though the tests are no longer spread
out over several months you will see
them in one single day
second novelty you will sit them
remotely you do not have to travel to a
test center any longer you can simply
set these tests remotely from your home
computer
of course the testing the remote testing
will be proctored meaning it will be
monitored before you start your test you
will have to show with your webcam that
you are alone in your room and that you
don't have any material
um to help you sitting these tests
so let's have a closer look at these
different stages
in order to apply you will need to
create an episode account and with this
episode count you can take take part in
as many competitions as you like you
apply via our website you can fill out
your application in any of the 24
official languages and this competition
or the application period for this
competition ends on the 25th of July
everybody who applies gets invited to
book a testing date and on that date you
will then sit the three tests mentioned
we start with testing your reasoning
skills numerical verbal and abstract
reasoning are tested in your first
language meaning the language other than
English
and in the last column you see the
passcode this is the minimum score you
need to obtain in order to stay in the
running for a place on the list of
successful candidates for numerical
reasoning you need at least 6 out of 10
for verbal and abstract reasoning
combined you need at least 15 out of 30.
you can of course score higher but you
need at least these pass scores
mentioned on this slide
I suggest you have a look on our sample
test page on the website because there
you can train this and by training these
kind of tests you get better at them
then we we will test the knowledge in
the field you will sit a field related
test in your second language and for
this competition it is English
this time the pass score is 15 out of 30
but your score will be ranked meaning
you need to score among the highest to
stay in the running for a place on the
list of successful candidates 15 out of
30 is a minimum will but will probably
not be sufficient to score among the
highest on the list
the third test is a case study again in
your second language English and with
this test we will test your drafting
skills this scoring is again a pass fail
score so you need to obtain at least 5
out of 10 but whether you score 5 6 7 8
or 9 of 10 it doesn't matter to pass
score is sufficient
after completing the testing phase we
will communicate your results and the
people who have obtained the minimum
pass Mark for the reasoning skills test
and the case study test and who scored
among the highest in the field related
test these people will be placed on the
so-called Reserve list or list of
successful candidates and this list is
the basis for recruitment
so when an institution has a vacancy
they will consult this list and invite a
number of people for a job interview and
the best match will then be offered the
job
I highly recommend you read the notice
of competition very carefully because in
this notice you will find all
information explained very detailedly
if you would still have more questions
you can always reach out to us through
the web form on our website or through
our social media channels
so for now I wish you success with this
competition and hope to see you on
another occasion bye bye